episode 2 begins where we left off with
officer Zaleski the kid has escaped
killing several guards in the process
cholesky draws his gun in pursuit only
to accidentally fire on his own CEO and
for us to find out it was all a figment
of his imagination out of you this begs
the question can the kid control
people's minds like what he did to the
mouse in episode 1 notice the cell doors
and the fingerprints I've never seen a
prison which keeps the inmates
fingerprints on display like that and if
you recall in episode 1 the kid got his
fingerprints taken obviously this was a
choice on the part of the director and
the production designer and it will be
interesting to see if this leads to
anything after creepily watching the kid
back in his cell we see the opening
titles which are filled with Stephen
King references I'm not gonna get into
too much detail about them since there
are already countless videos out there
explaining the titles but I do want to
spend a bit of time looking at this map
what excites me about this is castle
rocks relation to other fictitious
Stephen King towns such as dairy and
little tall island featured in the
miniseries the storm of the century this
means that we'll likely see references
to characters and stories beyond that of
Castle Rock proper take note of Augusta
where Allan Pangborn confronts warden
Porter at the Augusta Hilton later on in
the episode were then given a brief
history of Castle Rock narrated by
warden Lacey who committed suicide in
episode 1 he explains how the town has
hit hard times and is following a plan
and that plan isn't gods he asked if we
remember the dog reference to Cujo and
the strangler a reference to Frank Dodds
character in the dead zone we were then
transported to a football game in 1961
where the Castle Rock Cougars play
against the Angels and it's no
coincidence that they're playing against
a literal force of good
an angel which slams into young Dale
Lacey religion plays a huge role in this
episode and likely the series Lacey
makes reference to the fall after they
found that boy's body indicating a
connection to stand by me which connects
Castle Rock to LeAnn Chambers the wife
of one of the villains from that book
and who we saw put to death in episode 1
the school mascot who's Dale's brother
commits suicide I
that 57 years later his brother would do
the same thing we're then treated to
three jumps in time as Lacey shows how
his house was involved in a series of
gruesome deaths the first likely in 1941
due to the Time magazine featuring
Hitler shown here this issue is from
April 14 1941 take note also of the
cigarettes smoked roughly to the same
length as that in Episode one and the
dead body in the bathtub conjuring
images of the shining especially
considering seconds ago we saw a manual
typewriter all of these being conscious
choices by the production team we then
transitioned to what is likely the 1960s
based on the television and vintage beer
cans you can also see an ashtray with
cigarettes
to a man who has died from carbon
monoxide the final period is 1991 where
we see Dale Lacey leave carrying the
same lantern from episode 1 along with
the toolbox he crosses the same railroad
track which is now plastered with a
missing Henry Deaver poster the same
kind we saw Molly take out
Lacey ventures into cellblock F
explaining to us that hell is raising
some sort of quote raid on this town he
smokes a cigarette waiting for a sign
from God and we can see the can with the
butts is markedly less full than before
he says he's received a message from God
who instructs him on how to properly
build a cage for something of great evil
an evil that is perhaps the kid in
present-day Henry visits Martha Lacey
for information about the kid he sneaks
into Dale's study and uncovers a folder
full of newspaper clippings highlighting
strange events from Castle rocks past I
flipped the first page over thinking it
may contain some clues but unfortunately
it's just an article about a teen
getting burned by hot oil while working
as a cook at the sizzler so where do the
other pages are references to stand by
me Cujo and Leland gaunt the antagonist
from needful things Henry finds multiple
calendars all of them with the same
biblical passage from Acts 1633 this
chapter tells the story of a jailer who
asked the disciple Paul what he must do
to be saved in which Paul says quote
believe in the Lord Jesus and you will
be saved you and your household this
begs the question did Dale believed what
he was
doing was right if it meant saving
himself and his family is he fighting
for a greater cause
Martha kicks Henry out after discovering
he's Henry Deaver the boy suspected of
killing Reverend Deaver who was the head
of Martha's Church back in 91 but before
Henry leaves he remarks on a lock
leading into Dale's basement a lock that
is missing in episode 1 what mysteries
lie below will hopefully find out later
at the church were introduced to the
current pastor who runs a prayer partner
program with Shawshank he calls on Jacki
Torrance whose name is oddly similar to
Jack Torrance in the shining there's no
sign of any relation at least not yet
Henry questions the pastor about Dale's
connection to the church Dale wasn't a
fan rather I think considered nature's
Chapel it leads me to believe that the
forest will have a bigger role to play
in the supernatural occurrences around
Castle Rock Zaleski questions the kid
about what happened the night before but
justifies it to himself that it's brain
fog from lack of sleep do the new baby
on the way at a hotel bar in Augusta
Alan confronts the warden and tells her
a story about Dale who apparently
discovered the mystery of Castle Rock to
her surprise Alan knows about the kid
and implies that he's the devil stating
don't let that kid back in the water
tank warden Porter uncovers a gross box
of fingernails and a pair of scissors
Reeves decides to fix the kid problem by
bunking him in with a skinhead he's
reading William Golding's Lord of the
Flies a story about a group of children
who become Savage and kill each other
remember also the fly who hung around
the kid in episode 1 and was found in
Zaleski's coffee this scene between
Henry and Ruth is interesting because
Ruth's memory seems to be pretty good
she recalls events from Henry's past
that he doesn't remember and interesting
and odd reversal from what we saw in
episode 1 remember the mysterious person
watching Henry from next door
it's Mollie strand who's wearing the
questionable fashion choice of
sunglasses indoors
it seems Mollie and Henry knew each
other as kids in that she may have a
crush on him judging from his journal
and the fact her sister later calls her
a voyeur
but I don't think that's the case we'll
examine that a bit later
young Mollie watches as Henry's father
takes him out at two five
Dean in the morning this is likely not
the night of the disappearance since
it's not winter back in the present we
see Molly take a pill like in episode 1
Molly's sister tells her she's suffering
from social anxiety but Molly believes
she's some sort of psychic with the
ability to feel others empathy could she
possibly have something similar to John
Coffey in The Green Mile an ability to
see and feel the pain of others Molly
tells her sister she forged her
signature in order to get equity in
their parents home the forging signature
here could be a clue remember the Henry
Deaver signatures molly was writing over
and over again as a child look at the
difference in the signatures on the left
and the right and the ripped pages in
the middle could she be trying to forge
his signature back at Shawshank the
skinhead gets a little too close to the
kid the kid tells him you don't want to
touch me
but it's ambiguous whether that's a
threat or a warning at the Mellow Tiger
bar a bar featured in needful things
Jackie approaches Henry and asked him if
the rumors about how his father died are
true she also makes reference to Nan's
luncheonette another needful things nod
when Zaleski enters Henry remembers him
from the prison and hands him a napkin
with his phone number Henry finds Alan
digging up a neighborhood dog apparently
Ruth thinks it's still roaming around
and she asked Alan to check is he
telling the truth or is he digging it up
for other reasons back in 1991 a
detective questions Molly about Henry's
disappearance Molly says she doesn't
know anything but it's clear she's
hiding something when the detective
leaves we see her frozen breath even
though the breath of the other
characters weren't visible the only
explanation I have for this is that she
can feel Henry's pain out in the frozen
weather there is some sort of
transference here could Molly be the
reason Henry survived in present day
Henry finds a White Queen chess piece in
the fridge the devil was known to play
people in games of chess and the trailer
has shown that there are also crimson
chess pieces could Castle Rock be the
location of a great game between the
devil and God Henry has a secret meeting
with Celestia tells him more about the
kid Henry says he'll file habeas corpus
also the name of this episode which
states that if someone is being
unlawfully detained they must be brought
to court to determine if the detention
is
awful in order to do that so Leske would
need to be to pose which he won't do for
fear of losing his job and with a baby
on the way he's not willing to do that
Henry will then need proof that the
prisoner exists so the next day he
decides to join the pastor's prayer bus
at Shawshank the body of the skinhead
was wheeled out dead with no apparent
cause of death the guard says you sure
he's dead he was just lying there an
autopsy is done in the body and it's
found to be riddled with metastatic
cancer of the heart liver and lungs
which leads me to believe what exactly
is the extent of the kids powers so
Leske brings the kid to Henry as we hear
Dale's voice over explaining God told
him to quote never again let the kids
see the light of day but this begs the
question if God told him not to let the
kid oh how come he killed himself and
told the kid to ask for Henry was he
under the kid's control or is this all
part of some master plan
Henry yells of the kid telling him he
can be his lawyer before quickly
snapping a few pictures of him for
evidence we see the dog from episode 1
run through the forest and uncovered
Dale's decapitated head as the final
shot of the episode reveals that Dale's
voiceover was a letter to Alan Pangborn
a letter he sets on fire outside of
Shawshank this episode greatly expanded
on the story and gave us a better sense
of what the shows about while posing
more questions than answered what is the
relationship between Alan and Dale is
Alan the new defender of Castle Rock and
what role will Henry and the kid have to
play in the future we'll just have to
stay tuned and unlock the mysteries
together hey I hope you liked this video
if you liked it and want me to continue
doing more castle rock analysis make
sure to LIKE and subscribe the mysteries
are getting bigger and bigger and I look
forward to solving them with you
stay tuned for episode 3 coming out soon